what's up gang up some 25 ask don't know
how to ask itself gang I'd keep it the
rock you know like a dailyvee how are
you what episode is this going to be
c'est le b25 but d rock we've only put
out what 22 worse 23 when is it coming
hey sis
well good
you know snapchat
you have to really watch it that's where
all the good stuff is
never works
that's awesome
so you have been around the world in
bath 4000 time in the last 36 hours I
sure have
how are you here right now how I roll
will you win Bart it's true Gregg I've
been to Mars and back what's up man
is this is it I mean this is look this
is the game yeah you can see where I'm
at right now right like I think we need
to go tighter and deeper on what works
except I think when an episode of daily
B goes up you need to read the comments
the next morning on Facebook and YouTube
inevitably people are gonna be talking
about their favorite Park it's gonna be
home in New York temporarily happy
birthday in Iraq how old are you 25
and this might be episode 25 it's very
meta good might be 24 I can't what you
want to do is actually don't you know
like what do we do spend 22 it is
because there's stuff I talked about in
there at least we got it so that's some
help you didn't do any work
so why don't we do rework as a separate
piece of content put it up okay so do
that so this is 25 then because I like
it being 25 under earth day right so one
more time South by is 23 Australia is 24
okay this is 25 so you can have Stefan
start putting up we work as a separate
piece of content like like I think we
should just put that out yeah it's a
really good talk yeah I think that's
just a good keynote like we were keynote
in Boston with the date and that's it
what's that no I just want to keep it
the way it just was I think it's cool
that everybody gets to see how we just
figured that out why are we trying to
edit directa just sits there
Lizzie gets tripped down so I Mindy I
can get it done like like I don't all
right what else I'm sitting here the
dinner the dinners yeah
they those kind of that concept yeah yep
I have dates okay
25th of April I think one in April is
that's right that's it okay enables
isn't there a date already in place with
some of these guys vaynermedia and you
saw that little you know 7080 we got to
get we got to get much more Baynard
which is why I would move my podcast
that's gary vaynermedia needs to take
flight I just need to grow the business
a little bit more cool so those are two
vaynermedia that's two bit of media
things right yeah
yeah it's a net-net game show me it's on
him show me in six months later it's not
working it steps it's clearly steps none
of this [ __ ] happens overnight I think
that we have a good enough relationship
we're building relationship within the
building as a holistic thing and I know
what our best work is and I don't you
know what's clearly correct crazy is in
a b2b environment I've kind of like it's
stunning like how okay I am if none of
this ever happens because I just know
life like I'm just practical like I know
I don't get to make the call but what I
don't want to do is ever waver for what
is good for our top-line revenue I think
the reason I'm gonna build one of the
biggest companies is I want to do what
sell beer I just care about business by
the way real quick just because I know
we're just meaning I just really want
you to know why I'm only building this
for it to be the backbone of my own
private equity activity for my whole
life so I don't need your money I need
to know if it works so that I can go out
and buy you know the IP to Zima one day
yeah are you sir axel that's essentially
major same here
I'm John John how are you it's very very
rare when you see somebody like yourself
that is just from the heart and just
given and given and given and given
which is something that me and him are
similar as far as how we are with giving
and giving I mean even with feelers dude
what can happen feeling like crazy by
the past yes man yep
you know I think I think for you guys
and anybody just this conversation you
have to figure out where you're good at
right because that's the only thing you
should be doing okay if you can figure
out what you're good at
that's the only thing you should be
doing right that's the key the reason so
many people are doing the wrong thing
mentors mastermind [ __ ] is because
they're not good enough to win the right
way anybody that can win the right way
it's gonna win the right way
guys there's an entire world that has no
idea who these [ __ ] people are on
Instagram and internet marketers and
masterminds
it's called everybody else I know they
were there if you're good enough to make
money by doing that you do that it's the
people that are doing short-term gain
not talented enough so they're just
gonna sell people if you're gonna sell
information you can only sell what you
know
and problem with everybody selling
information is putting in a sell me how
to make a million dollars what are gonna
sell me had a little great life what do
you sell me how to be an entrepreneur
they're all full of [ __ ] so what yeah
somebody we don't look every day look
we're gonna sell me nothing that's true
you can only sell what you true and do I
think people would pay you 100 bucks a
month to sit on google stream and you be
their psychologist psychiatrist the
listening ear and you just tell your
real life stories how you found each
other you can tell me how to have long
distance friendships you can only sell
the truth so what I would do is reverse
engineer what you guys are about you
know you can sell me on being young
brown man in America because there's a
lot of [ __ ] going on with that but I
don't know that maybe you're really
helpful I don't know but you can only
sell me what's true that's the game not
posing as something you're not so you
might only make $31,000 a year because
people are only willing to spend a
hundred bucks a month to get bad advice
cuz it's not a very big mark it's a much
bigger market I'm gonna make you seven
[ __ ] figures passive everybody falls
for that so but then you build something
I make the least money out of my
expertise out of anybody online play
there's no mastermind
there's no funnel dailyvee doesn't stop
and then you have to pay $4.99 a week
and then once in a [ __ ] blue moon aka
every three [ __ ] years I asked for
$18 not a good business model
governments are firing people for not
filling out brackets then people will
start [ __ ] paying attention it's
serious around here
Gabe is this like you've been here
[ __ ] as a man are you really are you
really the excuse business I'm not
really like I'm such a winner you're
such a winner and you decided to go
excuse on me yeah thank you thank you so
wait a minute today's the first day of
the tournament and st. Patty's Day yeah
what a killer day for bars or they might
be upset they might have bastardized the
two days they might have lost
they got like 80% of it that happens a
lot on like like always like when
Christmas Eve falls on different days
not on Thursday or Friday or Saturday
for Wine Library well we'll try to get
through the st. Patty's Day Parade
great
do you know about my daily vlog I know
well I'm very upset congratulations
thank you car yeah
Tanner I am thinner
no with with who I'm sorry just a chop
for a second this one here you're gonna
like gentlemen may concern' rocks
birthday I know you sir yeah there's a
podcast we're kind of going like Barbara
Walters 191 yeah everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 191 of
the ask gary me show it was so much fun
you did such a great job you guys killed
it congratulations I'm so happy for you
guys I'll be back you didn't thank you
my pleasure brother continued success
yeah good luck honey power hello hello
I'm sorry I'm late Kelly Gary hi Lauren
nice to meet you good books can numbers
no no see that I'm saying
yeah next one next one glasses not your
boy what is this 70 books so this week
I'm book skin one compared to I want you
to add all them up I actually think I
saw more than every other book combined
on the list like all of them yeah
that's insane hello
Karina Gary are you all right let's go
just took a fun day today what do you
want to tell you - yes I'm here
hey guys I'm here yes just kind of uh I
would be lying if I didn't say I was
excited to hear that that's kind of
where your opening line went because it
does speak to building bigger businesses
and things of that nature just I'm just
excited about it while recognizing maybe
the first task at hand does go down just
a sales performance anger
anything you want add Wichern or is is
this a good kind of starting point to
contextualize because I I definitely
feel like I have a grasp of what you
guys are are focused on is there
so I'm ganging up some 25 ask don't know
not ask you okay I'll keep it be rock
you know like it a levy just kind of
feeling like always trying to find new
ways to play value to the daily blog
figured I just kind of talk to you guys
about stuff that's on my mind I think
I'll add some real depth practitioner
ships to the episode obviously it's
interesting to see me hustle but I think
I need to challenge myself constantly to
bring value that's all about what's
going on I think this could be kind of a
cool new feature like kind of what's
going on in the marketplace I think you
know today I had a bunch of client
meetings that it's crazy guys the
biggest companies in the world to start
it like it's like you can just taste it
in the air it's not just with you it's
not just a banner like like the way they
look at BuzzFeed the way they look and
snapchat incredible it's changing it'll
next five to seven years I think we're
gonna be in that post transition period
and it's been in remarkable world with
many of you in your 20s and 30s that
intuitively understand the value in the
ROI of these social media platforms
literally the guy I'm just on the phone
with you know like social because taking
over the world like people just want to
understand I'm trying to get you
come on Andy Rock
you rock for New Jersey
Oriana Nate
all right nope oh nice shout
[ __ ] filter thing is a big business
man yeah I think they got something for
now right like for a while bro is yeah I
think it's a good ad product for a year
snapchat filters I look at snapchat
filters the way I looked at hashtags for
Twitter years ago it was this new layer
on top of a platform that created
context when chris messina factor at
factory joe big shout out chris messina
created the hashtag cooked movement on
on twitter it added to the conversation
you could add this hashtag and you know
and all of a sudden all these events all
these conferences all these places would
create their own hashtag but hashtags
arent ownable you know you create a
hashtag like you know South by Southwest
or like a brand hashtag beautiful skin
well anybody can then use it and then
you click it and people are spamming and
all this stuff but filters filters on
snapchat snapchat has created context on
their platform in a way that's ownable
and monetizable twitter didn't make
money on the hashtag Iraq but snapchats
gonna make it and every one of you this
summer every wedding you go to of 23 to
29 year olds or every 27 to 34 year old
wedding you go to they're gonna have a
Geo filter a custom geo filter for that
wedding spot and everybody's gonna take
all their pictures and it's gonna say
Karen and Rick forever 2016 that's
incredible
like every Bar Mitzvah every Bar Mitzvah
in America is gonna have a custom
snapchat filter in 12 months like I'm
gonna be buying custom filters for you
know business conferences that I'm not
even gonna be at it's gonna be like oh
it's me say hello like this is an
unbelievably subtle interesting thing
that scales infinitely there's four
filters who knows they may go up her
thing and so I'm fascinated by snapchat
filters as a business model and as a
context point and as an explosion in the
same way that your dad now sends you an
emoji watch these filters just take over
and watch people screen shoot and then
put
on their Facebook and put it on our
insta and put it on their Twitter big
believer right now all-in-all chips in
on snapchat custom filters and for three
or four review designers that are
watching right now brand yourself as a
custom snapchat filter designer and a
hundred percent a hundred dirac percent
predict somebody will email me about
episode 25 of daily be and how that
built their business because they
listened right now made a profile made a
landing page on tumblr or on Squarespace
or WordPress position themselves as a
custom snapchat filter producer writes
an article about it maybe wins the lucky
SEO game and literally literally nine
months from right now you're making you
know 50 filters a day you've got two
people working for you and you're making
you know 50 bucks 100 bucks 200 bucks
500 bucks a filter and you know I'm
right
and I'm so damn right so that's very hot
I'm excited about that musically picking
up steam picking up steam really winning
in junior high you guys have heard me if
you follow me talking about that just
got the book scam numbers that's what's
happening today I'm gonna probably make
a poster of this I don't know if I can
publicly put this out but how many books
I sold in business more than everybody
else in the category combined incredible
fantasy baseball super focused on my
fantasy baseball team the NCAA
tournament I had Yale in the upset so
I'm pumped about that
doing pretty good they're just feeling
good good to be home tomorrow I have to
apply to Pittsburgh and back so more
hustling so a lot of that stuff going on
Sunday night I'm heading to Dublin I
don't even know you know this Meir after
that I have a funny feeling this will
air but you'll probably ended this in
Dublin or London the Iraq
thank you for having me but I'm excited
about my trip there so I can feel
comfortable in saying that you'll
probably edit actually you didn't film
it's me interesting this this one might
be delayed but that's what's going on
today a little recap of the day it was
cool the light went out at the same time